this week on couch tomatoes we're
talking Apple TV pluses new original
shows like the morning show serving and
for all mankind and giving you our fresh
picks on what else to watch hello
friends welcome back to couch tomato
sponsored by Frechette a pizza I'm your
host as Perez and today on the show
we're diving deep into Apple TV Plus and
here to help me break it all down is TV
host Heather gardener hi TV critic at
indieWIRE Ben Travers Lou and TV host
Jackie I didn t see what's up guys you
excited yes so pumped I am excited I'm
stoked to talk about this because it's
new streaming service debuted on
November 1st at $4.99 a month I feel
like most of my friends have iPhones but
a lot of people don't know about Apple
TV plus or don't have it so if that's
you we're gonna help you guys out today
because we're gonna answer the question
does Apple TV Plus have enough
compelling content to be worth it right
now hopefully by the end of the episode
I want to know what shows set out to you
guys right off the bat
oh I was most excited and I subscribed
the very first day and was so excited
because of the morning show hmm that was
the one that drew me in it was Jennifer
Aniston's return to television oh I
watched it that night that Friday night
yeah yeah who needs a friend's reboot
when we got Jen on mornings okay we're
set out to even well I mean it's the
morning show like the morning show is
their premiere program that was the one
that everybody was supposed to be
looking forward to the everybody was
excited about you had Reese Witherspoon
you had Jennifer Aniston you had Mimi a
leader you've had Carrie Aaron like all
of these people could take hand to make
a good show like they just had to make a
good show and then I was really excited
to see Dickinson I loved period pieces
and it kind of intrigued me that they
were making this modern take on it so I
wasn't quite sure what to six expect but
I was really excited about that one yeah
I love to consent it's so dope and
speaking of it you and I actually spoke
earlier about fun ways to set the tone
at home when you're watching a period
piece so check it out all right now so I
know how much you
of shows from different time periods
right yeah we talked about this all the
time I love the fashion I love the
trends I just feel like everything was
so much fancier back then so much
fancier but you know what I love the
most actually was the mills you know we
can eat you know we can eat I made you
this for shut up brick oven spinach and
mushroom pieces the mushrooms the
spinach the mozzarella cheese all of it
together is basically like a 12-course
meal within itself and what sounds
fancier than brick oven nothing exactly
and I'd love to pair with wine and this
fancy tableware cuz you know maestra
your heart extra but you know what I
kind of don't mind it cuz now I feel
like a proper lady you are properly
should but wait how does a proper lady
eat her pizza with her pinkie uh-oh all
right guys let's dive deep into Apple
TV's latest and greatest the show
everyone's talking about right now
servant currently highest rated out of
all the Apple TV Plus shows and
certified fresh' with an 83% on the
tomato meter the show follows a couple
coping with the loss of their son
Jericho but still pretending that he's
still alive so creepy it's so I think
creepy is probably there behind closed
very Jerry sets that tones so well
because the premise itself is so unusual
and as M night Shyamalan talked about
before the show came out it's based in
this real form of therapy in which you
know if you lose a child you can use
this kind of baby as a replacement or
fake baby doll whatever we want to call
it as a replacement to kind of get
through your grief to try to you know
progress forward and yet this couple
seems to be so stagnant that they bring
in an actual servant to take care of the
baby when they don't need one because
it's not real so it's this great premise
where you're like oh my gosh what's
gonna happen here how did the you know
what happened to the baby what where's
the servant coming from why is she going
along with it maybe it holds water for a
pretty good amount of time but
eventually you just kind of lose the
thread like it didn't really connect for
me enough to make it worth finishing all
10 episodes how many of us does you see
I mean I finished all 10 episodes
like you have to go through the whole
thing where do you feel like it's
dropped off for you I feel like right in
the middle you started to feel like okay
you could pick up the pace a little bit
or I want to know more about this or
this doesn't seem to be as important as
it needs to be but you're you're creeped
out throughout like it's a pretty it's a
pretty strange show throughout its
entire run and there's great
performances within there it's beautiful
to look at they do a great job with that
one scene you know the one setting the
fact that it all takes place in this big
old Philadelphia house like a little bit
outside of it that helps kind of create
this eerie vibe throughout but it just
kind of I don't know it just kind of
fizzled for me at the end it wasn't
scary enough if it was gonna be a horror
show
right see for me this show made Apple TV
plus worth it like before this show
because it released later on November
28th they released three episodes we
have three episodes right now and I was
just like this is what we love from M
night Shyamalan you know like the shots
of the hallways the staircase the big
twist it's like creepy but also
hilarious like when he drops the doll I
was dying laughing and I feel like all
those questions you were saying like I
feel like it built intrigue right off
the bat Shyamalan opened up and said
that he needs about six seasons to tell
the full story of servant which I
thought was interesting but it also got
renewed for a second season even before
it's premieres if you want to jump in I
think this one's worth it but let's move
on to the show that I feel like you guys
are most excited to talk about everyone
at home was so stoked on the most
anticipated the morning show like you
said starring Jen Aniston Steve Carell
Reese Witherspoon so this show follows
the aftermath of a morning show after
its main host gets fired for sexual
misconduct 63% on the tomato meter mixed
reviews but a 94% audience scores I feel
like people everyone feels some type of
way about this show what did you guys
think I have some very strong feelings
this was the reason that I had to get
Apple TV Plus this was I'm gonna hook me
in I swore no not another streaming
service and yet I saw this Perry and I
thought okay I can do what I can baby
and I think for me I just overhyped it
so much in my brain because we live in
this TV world the newsroom is one of my
all-time favorite television shows I
love anything where I could see like
myself reflected on TV as we all do as
we all like I think I just overhyped it
so much and I just felt like this just
only scratch the surface of all these
really important issues we up a good
point cuz my whole
thing was like well do I just love this
because I work in TV you know what do
you think banning ie I'm very much in
the same boat like the idea to me was it
was I really wanted to get invested in
the people and I wanted to get invested
in the drama and kind of all of the
behind the scenes intrigue and I've had
a lot of people kind of talk to me about
the morning show in the sense of like
well it's so bad it's good like you can
enjoy it almost because it's just so
soapy and you don't have to worry about
it and I think it's effective at that I
don't even think they get that level
just right the most compelling aspect of
the show to me was just kind of trying
to see what they were gonna do next in
this not complete train wreck but
something that was definitely off the
rails right and whenever you're looking
for the those kind of formal problems I
think that's good TV like I don't take a
lot of enjoyment in that yeah and it
straightens out a bit toward the end but
yeah I just it didn't really connect
like it's no I'm kind of opposite I
really enjoyed it and I don't know if
kind of like what you said Heather
because we're in the fields we kind of
relate more to it but I really did enjoy
the storyline and I loved the
relationships in this series as well but
I think it did drop off a little bit I
didn't really understand the tone of the
show one minute it's like this serious
conversation the next it's like
overdramatic and the dialogue it just
doesn't fit very well so it wasn't it
wasn't like one tone for me that's what
kind of and that's it took me back I
loved it they had so many issues to deal
with of course the me2 movement they
dealt with women's anger and they dealt
with diversity in the workplace and they
touch on all of those things but I
didn't really get invested in any one of
those things because there was so much
that they wanted to say and I just felt
like they didn't say anything I agree
and for me the most interesting
character was Mitch Kessler and I'm like
he's the most complex but he also is
accused of sexual misconduct and then
you have some diverse ancillary
characters at work in the newsroom but
their stories aren't that complicated
and interesting I'm like why I care
about these people I love the show I
really love watching I'm not really I
get excited every Friday but there's a
little part of me that's like I think I
just hope it was a little bit better
definitely
Mitch Kessler is such a problem for the
show because Steve Carell is a great
actor and you always want to watch the
thrill and the idea of kind of casting
somebody who's kind of a Nate Lee
lovable and that you really want to
watch TV show about I think that's great
for this kind of person because they're
trying to you know show why that's not
okay like why the behind the scenes drum
is the real problem here but
so much pity and empathy evoked for this
guy who is a monster like who did
something really terrible yeah by the
end of this the first season they kind
of come around on that to show why they
spent so much time with him but for
those first five six seven episodes it
doesn't really you don't really
understand why you're feeling that way
and then even by the end you kind of
want to know more about him even though
you shouldn't even though you should be
writing them off and being like let's
move on interesting well I would like to
move on to a show guys let's talk about
see lowest-rated
on the tomato meter at 41% audiences are
liking the show stars Jason Momoa takes
place in an alternate universe 600 years
into the future he is the father of
these twins that have the ability to see
unlike everyone else in the show and
he's sort of trying to protect them and
his tribe from this Queen that wants to
destroy them mm-hmm I have never the
narrative was so convoluted for me
yep that I was like I don't know what's
happening but Ben do you think the show
is worth watching I was one of the one
of the few people who who thought it was
actually so silly and weird that it was
kind of worth investing in if that was
something you were looking for like if
you were looking for a fantasy show that
was trying to build this strange new
world it was like okay like you can give
that a shot and see if this is for you I
still don't think it's good okay great
when I saw the storyline and what it was
about it was just like this is a recipe
for disaster but to what you're saying
there was something about it that was
intriguing that I couldn't stop watching
it I kept watching episode after episode
I was invested in the characters really
even though on paper it's like okay this
world where everyone's blind do I like
it just didn't really make sense to me
but I really loved it and I feel like
they made it for Jason Momoa
specifically rock-climb and I felt like
it was something that his family would
do every episode is something that he
would actually do in real life yeah I
enjoyed that part well you mentioned the
world
I feel like this does have world
building capabilities this show even
though it wasn't for me personally do
you guys feel like it's the next
with Thrones oh no and it has those work
you know I mean that's what their
attempt was for sure every single
service every single network every
single person in television is trying to
capture that magic in that audience and
there is a void left and I watch the
trailer and I wanted I wanted to feel
that way because I love that show so
much and I couldn't do it and you know
what I haven't found it on any other
streaming service either I don't really
have the model because it doesn't exist
yet yeah I want to support it because I
know some of the cast and crew are blind
and or have low vision which I thought
was really Joe but I just wish it was I
don't know sometimes you just want to
watch TV and not have to think and do
math you know I'm just like just give it
to me and I feel like I know how to
figure things out way it was very
complicated I just left every single
episode feeling very confused with more
questions than answers and it just made
me not care so much about it it's really
hard to do the world-building in a way
where it's all feels new and fresh but
it also is kind of intuitive which I
always thought was kind of weird because
Apple like prides itself on that they're
very intuitive with their products with
their with their iOS with all of that
and yet the show itself is just very
confusing like you can't just jump in
and be like oh I get why they're doing
that I know why they made that choice it
has to be explained and even though yeah
we all have iOS and a lot of people
don't even know about sea but let's move
from alternate universe to alternate
history with for all mankind now this
show is one of the highest praise shows
on Apple TV plus 71% on the tomato meter
takes place in an alternate history
where the United States loses to the
Soviets in the space race and then falls
second again when the Soviets put a
woman on the moon first now I was
watching the show and I feel like a lot
of the brilliance is hidden in the pilot
because it wasn't until the third
episode where I was like oh this is the
show this is fantastic is it fair to ask
people to wait until the third episode
for the story to pick up what do you
guys think I thought the same thing this
is one that I didn't really know
anything about and I'm not really drawn
to like history period pieces anyway and
so I was like I just give it a shot and
it was the one that I liked the most and
was most surprised about but I will
agree I agree with you I was like when
are we gonna get there because the
trailer shows this women female
empowerment which I love to see on
screen and I'm like come on when when
are we gonna get there but I'm so
excited every time it ends because I
just want to press play oh the next one
I feel like with so many shows out there
you kind of do need to hit your audience
right off the bat or people will fall
off they'll find something more
interesting to watch so I feel like you
got to have something and that first
episode to draw you in and I feel like
they just didn't have that in the first
episode I was kind of bored after that's
so many of the choices in the first
episode seemed to be antithetical to
what you're talking about like the best
character in that first episode is the
woman who's sleeping at NASA trying to
[Laughter]
mistake that she makes her she didn't
speak up in time and you're like okay
she's gonna correct that by the end of
it and instead they completely abandon
that storyline and follow up with her
and then instead they're focused on this
you know Joel Kinnaman kind of failed
pilot who makes a mistake and is kind of
grumpy and angry and yelling a lot
you're like I've seen that guy I don't
care about him like I just appreciated
so much the care that they took and
Isetta me absolutely save me the planes
and automobiles and so but do you Jackie
Ben do you guys like the show for all
mankind except Ben Trevor I think
alternate history shows are tough
especially with this one because there's
so many lesser known facts about this
era that for me was confusing
I like found myself googling like maybe
we did it it wasn't no because I learned
more about Apollo 10 but anyway I'm glad
to know how off screen alia was looking
up what really I found I found myself
googling that this really happened what
really did happen but that to me just
kind of Drew me more I learned and I was
excited about well Heather we also got a
Florida Education so that's at okay so
let's talk about Dickinson I'm actually
really excited you can send begin to
your most venerable show all 10 episodes
came out when the streaming service
premiered the episodes are 30 minutes
long follows the life it's a highly
stylized version of the life of Emily
Dickinson stars Hailee Steinfeld and
it's like there's a lot of modern Sense
and Sensibility what do you guys think
about Dickinson loved it
I blew through it I watched the entire
ten
season 10 episode season in two days
just I loved it I loved it
but I also had big feelings about it
because I loved period pieces and I felt
like I thought it was innovated that
they were mashing the two together
modern and past but why choose that
story and do it in such a all over the
place kind of way do you go what I mean
well I'm gonna push back and say that I
think it was because Emily Dickinson the
real life person was just really strange
she was obsessed with death she was a
reclusive person in her home that really
never left her father's house her entire
life and she didn't get popular until
after her death like she was a pretty
strange person yes I read her work so to
me it actually felt like a very honoring
way to describe her line I feel like
that's all we learn about her in school
is she was this poet from the 1800s I
never left her room her poems were
published afterwards but what I love
about this show is that they pull
aspects of her life
lesser at lesser known aspects of her
life and put it in the plot like the
fact that she's queer in the show I love
that they explore that Ben what did you
think of - I agree I think I think it's
kind of in-between those reactions I do
feel like what they choose to focus on
in terms of Emily's backstory and how
progressive she was and the stuff that
kind of gets shoved to the side was
great and I loved the performances I
loved the design of it and at the same
time a lot of those kind of modern
touches that they try to do especially
with the language I don't know how well
they incorporate that like that kind of
pulls me out from time to time which
made it not quite as addictive as I
wanted to be but by time we got to the
third episode you're flying I think that
party scene if you just lean into the
weirdness because the show does and it
does take a few minutes and a few
episodes to kind of get into the
weirdness but they go right in if you
can just let go and lean in and close
your eyes and pretend that you're just
watching the meme on the internet oh
yeah yeah you're gonna love it and
that's what I did I just went with it
but that's what I feel like I totally
love weirdness and I'm all about that
and I wanted to lean into the weirdness
but then it's also trying to go with the
pack it just felt like there was I
didn't know where to lean - yeah there's
elements that felt very natural like
like when rain again when the party
started and the music is going and
people are dancing and they have the
montage like all of that feels very
natural and there's just little moments
where it feels
they're trying to force something yeah
that's where you're taking back out of
it again and you're kind of reminded
this isn't real this isn't exactly foes
death who do you think it shows for oh
man it's for the teens seems yeah Apple
needs that audience to kind of be
attracted to the service to try to drive
people to it they may not be the number
one subscribers they may not be the
people paying the bills but if they
really want the service and they get
people talking about it that's that's
absolutely crucial to a good range and I
think there's one thing that's evident
here is Apple TV cares about a lot of
female-led shows yeah I love but I know
they also have a lot of shows coming up
so now that we've talked about the shows
that we have what are some shows coming
up that you guys are excited about
because I know Apple TV Plus as
announced they do have more original
series on the way I am most excited to
see Steven Spielberg and this is his
this is his launch into the streaming
world and the reason I'm excited about
amazing stories is because he has just
been so vocal about being against
streaming services he was he has gone in
this whole battle with netflix for over
a year now just trying to get this old
hollywood distribution and saying that
basically putting up his little pinky
and saying that his way of life in
hollywood is the right way and here he
is now kind of just settling into the
streaming service or i want to be blown
away and I want the amazing stories to
be that top-of-the-line content that he
thinks that he's the only one he can
produce and tell an amazing and tell an
amazing story don't remake - man what
are you excited Steve's okay with this
phone because it's TV like it's not a
film old way of thinking that I'm just
like get over it come on move on yeah I
completely agree and I'm probably most
excited for the return of one of my
favorite TV actors in the Mosquito Coast
Justin Theroux is working on an
adaptation of a book that was written by
his I think his uncle I believe it's
it's it's another Thoreau in the family
and this was a film made by it's
Harrison Ford is starring in it it's a
new kind of take on that original book
and the film itself and now they're
developing it for Apple and you know I
just love Justin throw I'm ready for him
to come back and do whatever the heck he
wants to do laughs just a weird kind of
scientist who's taking his family to an
island like
let's do just ya Justin throw do that I
loved him a maniac too more he brings
his dog around town the better to shame
Jackie what are you looking forward I'm
really excited for swagger the story
about Kevin Durant's life I feel like
what you guys were saying earlier Apple
is trying to get all these different
audiences and I feel like that is a new
audience that they're gonna bring to
Apple TV and I mean I'm not even a huge
sports fan but something about Kevin
Durant's life really intrigues me so I'm
excited to see that
I love Duran Chawla and I love that
that's also a new diverse show because
even though they have an Oprah I don't
feel like there are a lot of diverse
stories being told currently at the
moment I'm really excited for Lizzy
story it's based on the Stephen King
novel by the same name it's an ape our
episode series and it stars Julianne
Moore and Stephen King's writing the
episodes being like Pet Sematary then
I'm not so sure
okay guys so now that we've talked about
all the shows on Apple TV Plus and the
show is coming out how do you guys think
Apple TV Plus stacks up against its
competition I mean the having Disney
Plus come out relatively around the same
time Jamie hill them I've been seeing
predictions that saying that Apple TV
Plus can have a hundred million
subscribers which by like 2023 and I
just have to laugh and that I just do
not find that plausible I don't yeah I
mean it's it's it's difficult to me
because what Apple TV Plus is trying to
do is very different from what the other
streaming services are trying to do
they're not just competing on this on
their originals or on their library
content they're trying to get people to
use the app they're trying to get people
to subscribe through the app for HBO now
for Showtime for stars for Hulu for
Netflix and then create this kind of
service within the app where you know
the originals are a nice kind of treat
they're a nice bonus you get to watch
some of the things that you can't watch
anywhere else but at the same time you
get to have all of your content
organized in this one unified place it's
almost like they're getting ahead of the
bundling which we're not which we
haven't had seen happen yet with
services and they're trying to like
start that trend so I think it could be
successful I think it could be something
that people are into but they need those
originals to drive it a little bit
better they need the originals to serve
that product for five bucks a month it's
just if you want to use it yeah yeah
yeah I think it might be too soon to
tell I know that they're putting out a
lot more shows
working on it but I just feel like they
as of right now they don't have enough
original content to compared to the
other streaming sites I don't think and
as we've seen after we've talked about
all the shows there wasn't one or two
that we were like you need to get Apple
TV and I think that's a bad start every
one of these shows we've talked about
had them renewed for a second season so
you might as well just wait because
you're gonna blow through a very limited
amount of content that they have right
now and they're gonna be wondering why
am i paying $5 a month for the next six
months to have nothing new so let's wait
and that's like what the thing is if you
wait we also have peacock coming in
April 2020 NBCUniversal z-- you know and
you're gonna have things like the office
Xing reg 3,000 hours of Telemundo and
reportedly varieties reporting that
that's gonna be free and run with ads
and then you have HBO Mac's coming out
in May of 2020 so I agree I think maybe
wait but let's go down the line is Apple
TV plus worth it or not and obviously
it's worth it if you bought a new iPhone
it's free but really what I'm asking
here is Ben if you didn't get paid to
watch Apple TV would you buy it bench
reverse I would but only because it's $5
a month which is you get if you for that
month if you find one thing you want to
watch that's cheaper than renting one
movie like for right now so I think for
that if there's something you want to
watch it is worth it the price point
really did sell it because I was
thinking it would have to be but this
premium content that they were pumping
out these I mean they spent almost 300
million dollars per you know season
prove per show here that's a lot of
money and so I thought it was gonna be a
lot more money for my iPod in my pocket
5 bucks a month it's like okay I can do
it it's less than a water bottle at the
airport was any higher if it was 10 or
15 dollars which what is what I thought
it was going to be for that content I
wouldn't have done it but five bucks
it's like alright I can I can definitely
if there's one show that you are
invested in or want to get to know on
that platform then it's worth it I want
to continue to watch the morning show so
five dollars a month to watch a whole
series how bad I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
it home I feel like that I feel like
just maybe wait like you were saying
yeah alright guys well hopefully we
helped you guys answer the question is
Apple TV
worth it or not but now it's time for my
favorite part of the show your fresh
picks under the radar recommendations
what you're watching on TV that you feel
like people should be watching at home
okay I am into Dollface on Hulu and I
like it for the same reason that I
really like Dickinson actually it's
weird
it kind of bends reality in a really
smart and clever way and I would I would
argue not as clever as it is it's really
fun and it's very girly and I just
absolutely love Shay Mitchell and Brenda
song and their connection on the screen
I just want I just wanna be their
friends yeah I've sold me I'm like okay
I'm gonna go watch it now yeah yeah I'm
like I'm gonna watch that but banovitz
here fresh bag my biggest mrs. Fletcher
on HBO I absolutely adore pretty much
everything Tom prade has ever done and
this is the first time he's been the
sole showrunner on the show and he's
handled it beautifully like it's his own
book that he's a he's adapting for HBO
and these half-hour chunks it's a 7
episode series so it's gonna be over
pretty quick but you get to really enjoy
Kathryn Hans performance and she's just
so amazing and to have a showcase for
her like this is so wonderful to see
and yet the ensemble just continues to
spring to life as the episodes roll out
so it's something you can just fall into
and really love and I'm going to be
yelling at people to try to renew it and
watch her about mrs. Fletcher's about a
woman who kind of has empty nest
syndrome like she her son goes off to
college he doesn't know what to do with
herself and she falls into this kind of
world of pornography but the pornography
is more about her kind of expanding
herself as a person and seeing the
interesting you had me at pornography
[Laughter]
I'm obsessed with the show a typical on
Netflix it surrounds the story of this
kid that has autism and it's all about
relationships in this show that you have
quirky relationships with his sister and
his sister with this girl she's trying
to test out her sexuality and it's just
it's really great I love it everybody
needs to watch it so I've been watching
I don't know if you guys are gonna laugh
Fraser on Netflix really Fraser was
always a thing that was just playing in
the background that my parents
when I was little and I never really
watched it or understood it and I and
it's on Netflix so I turned it on and I
was like wow this is like as if sign
fell if everyone in Seinfeld went to an
Ivy League school it's so smart so funny
and I just love freesia I'm watching
freezer I need to cut brush up on all
those older shows yeah that's a mini
shows I know so many shows wow it's good
to have recommendations alright alright
guys well that is our show
Heather Ben Jackey thank you guys so
much for joining me on the couch today
for more on these shows and Apple TV
plus head on over to Ron Tomatoes calm
also comment below and let us know what
you think about Apple TV plus so far and
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and notification bell you know
you want to so you don't miss any future
couch tomato episodes i'm Nazz perez and
we'll see you guys next time bye cheers
guys yeah
[Music]